oh great so much for baggles so much for
what the meta comedy series community
has hit Netflix and fans both new and
old are very excited and now talks of a
possible movie are heating up so let's
look at the possibility of that
happening and what we can expect from it
right now on the catch up a season 2
episode of community featured a joke
about a failing TV show lasting six
seasons and a movie which then became a
catchphrase in the community fanbase and
beyond and after a five season run on
NBC with a sixth and final season airing
on the short-lived Yahoo screen in 2015
community is now only missing the and a
movie part but with its recent success
on Netflix questions about a movie or
coming in hot you know like sweet onions
and cast and crew have been responding
show star Joel McHale told Variety
recently I would say there's a better
chance than there's ever been and now I
think with the renewed interest and I
know the cast is interested that it
could happen and this is a man that
didn't after show with the tiger King
cast or miss couch so you know
anything's possible guys yes we were all
just thinking that McHale isn't the only
one offering optimism from his couch
though Danny Pudi told comicbook.com
that he believes it's gonna happen and
Alison Brie told fans in a reddit AMA
recently that they should stay tuned so
I guess that cheese in my fridge isn't
the only breathe it's teasing me these
days haha that was even the Russo
brothers who served as executive
producers and directors on the first few
seasons of the show are ready and
willing to do the movie Joe Russo told
Collider
it'd certainly be scheduled depending
for us but I believe there will be a
community movie especially now that it's
doing so well on streaming do we think
Joe and Anthony are quarantine together
just curious and show creator Dan Harmon
despite being very busy with another
show he created called brick and Morty
you may have heard of it is also into
the idea of a community movie he told
the independent quote certainly ideas
have been kicked around but he did
acknowledge that while most of the cast
remains closed getting everyone back
together could be difficult you know
seeing as childish gambino is a
full-fledged famous person now Donald
Glover left community in season 5 to
pursue other things like his blossoming
music
and to become the showrunner and star of
the Emmy winning show Atlanta so
needless to say the man is busy can we
get a kids meal and then there's Chevy
Chase who unexpectedly left the show
toward the end of season four following
years of rumored issues like butting
heads with Harmon leaving the set before
his scenes were done filming and being
verbally abusive to other cast mates and
the fact that he hasn't been involved in
any press for Communities arrival to
Netflix is probably not a good sign guys
you're bald
but as far as what we can expect from a
potential community movie if this were
to happen Joe Russo pointed out that
aside from the occasional genre
exploration episodes part of what is so
compelling about the show is that it's
very quaint
it's Greendale as an underdog so in
other words it wouldn't need to be done
with a big budget he even suggested
Netflix could be a great place to pull
it off so wink wink someone tagged
Netflix down below wearing protective
goggles to destroy my car safety first
all right friends it's time for us to
kick it over to you guys now what do you
want to see in a community movie let us
know all your thoughts and feelings in
the comment section and for more
streaming news head on over to Rotten
Tomatoes calm and be sure to join our
fan group on Facebook it's a social
distancing way to connect with fellow
members of the Quecha crew and if you
don't want to miss out on any future
episodes of this show hit that subscribe
button and notification bell so you
don't miss out on anything and as always
thank you guys for watching to catch up
my name is nas Prez and we'll see you in
the next video bye
[Music]